بيان صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم قال تعالى انا من
المجرمين
منتقمون صدق الله العظيم اطلقت قواتنا
المسلحه بعون الله تعالى دفعه من الصواريخ
البالستيه على اهداف مختلفه وحساسه للكيان
الاسرائيلي جنوب الاراضي المحتله منها
اهداف عسكريه في منطقه ام الرشراش
ايلات وبفضل الله تعالى فقد حققت العمليه
اهدافها بنجاح وادت الى اصابات مباشره في
الاهداف المحدده رغم تكتم العدو على ذلك
ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه مستمره في
تنفيذ عملياتها
العسكريه نصره لمظلوم الشعب الفلس
وحتى يتوقف العدوان الاسرائيلي على
اخواننا في غزه وما النصر الا من عند الله
صنعاء الخ من ربيع الاخر
1445 للهجره الموافق التاسع من نوفمبر
2023 صادر عن القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه
n